Mother's wedding ring.
I lost mine in the bombing so my mother gave me hers.
My earrings.
I make jewelry,...
...all the jewelry of my people.
It symbolizes freedom.
No one tells me what to wear.
Heart necklace.
Virgin Mary necklace.
Bracelet.
No, the bracelet's not my favorite thing.
That's Nancy, she's my doll.
The night we fled, my mother put her on my bed so we would not forget her.
But in all the rush, she did get left behind.
I don't mind, she'll keep watch.
Watch.
Digital...
...and analog.
Family portrait.
Photos.
A photo of my father,...
...memories of my father.
I have nothing from my home.
Everything was broken in the struggle.
We were out in just ten minutes.
They destroyed the house around my sick bed.
The neighbors heard me shout and came and carried me out.